Update on the curse. I look like I'm gonna be a church leader.
Like, what, who,
who evil I'd be.
So the place that I'm going that I go to get my hair cut,
I'm inside. Iron
automatically does, like,
blowouts, and he already started blowing my hair,
and it, like,
was too frizzy to put gel in.
So I was like, whatever.
Just finished a lot.
And I literally look like I am going to church on Sunday
and gonna bring a casserole dish with me.
Like, I. I.
No matter how I, like,
lay this hair, I just look so,
like, matronly
and I don't know how to, like,
I'm not meant. I'm not meant for blowout hair.
And I was like, maybe I can clip it and, like.
But the thing is, the bangs.
Like, I finally.
I cut bangs after a while
cause I saw,
like, see this, guys?
I look fucking old. I look old and elderly.
I look bad.
Also, my nail.
This is not on the nail bed,
so I can't get long nails.
So let's recap. And it's fashion week.
Let's recap. Glasses,
broken nails, short hair,
not curly. Who am I?
Who, what, who.
Who am I? Because this.
I don't. Okay,
someone's pregnant. And thing is,
the thing is, the thing is,
I'm gonna handle it. Like,
I'm gonna figure it out. But someone,
someone is praying on my downfall,
and I don't know which one of you bitches
it Is I have some names.
But I am going to be sending these curses back out 10 folds.
Watch your back.